what's interesting about all three of  you guys is like i feel like out of all  the major like rap crews in hip-hop like  when we think of like wu-tang clan like  really the only outsider of the original  nine that was ever considered a real  wu-tang member was cappadon right right  everybody else was like affiliates right  right right you guys were all dipset  like we know that you know what i'm  saying no we know that this is and so  that's why it just to me like it is too  because they started out as jim  freaky zekey jewels and cam right as the  diplomats  when we came along it was dipset  so when people scream dip said  that's us too  you know  how cuz